[sad music]
- [coughs]
NURSE,
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU DIE?
- I DON'T KNOW,
BUT YOU'LL FIND OUT
VERY SOON, BILLY.
NOW, GET SOME REST.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE TIRED
FOR HEAVEN.
- BUT I ALWAYS WISHED
I COULD GO TO PARIS
AND SEE THE EIFFEL TOWER.
NURSE?
OH.
- DID SOMEBODY SAY,
"THE EIFFEL TOWER?"
- [gasps]
GARY THE WHEELCHAIR?
- HOP ON!
LET'S GO SEE THE WORLD.
WHEE!
- WHOA!
WOW, THE EIFFEL TOWER.
OH, GARY, CAN WE SIT ON
THE VERY TOP OF THE TOWER?
- SURE.
OH, HEY, WHAT'S THAT?
OH, NO, YOU DON'T NEED
ALCOHOL ANYMORE, GARY,
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
A WHEELCHAIR NOW, REMEMBER?
[dreamy harp music]
I'M OKAY TO DRIVE.
OOH, ONE MORE WON'T HURT.
HUH?
[tires squealing]
[truck crashing]
- [screams]
MY LEGS!
[crying]
WHAT HAVE I DONE?
[dreamy harp music]
- GARY?
- UH--OH, NO.
NO, I GOT TO STAY STRONG.
- GARY, IT'S HOT UP HERE.
I'M THIRSTY.
- YEAH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
SCREW IT.
HOLD ON, KID.
WHEE!
[club music]
BEEP, BEEP, COMING THROUGH.
- WHOA!
- HEY, TOOTS, NEED A SEAT?
♪
- [groaning]
GARY?
- [coughing]
HEY, DADDY BOY,
WANT A LAP DANCE?
[coughing]
- OKAY,
BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DANCE.
- WHEE, HOLD ON, BILLY!
COMING THROUGH.
LOOK OUT.
HI, GIRLS.
♪
YEAH, GIRL.
I WISH I COULD THANK YOUR DADDY
FOR MESSING YOU UP SO GOOD.
SHAKE THAT.
MMM.
- NO, NO, NO, NO.
GET AWAY FROM ME.
- GARY, CAN WE GO
TO THE TOWER NOW?
- OKAY, JUST ONE MORE DRINK.
- [coughs]
YOU READY FOR YOUR LAP DANCE?
- ALMOST GOT IT.
- [straining for breath]
- [gasps]
YOU KILLED HER, GARY!
- UH, QUICK, KID,
GRAB THIS BOTTLE
AND POUR THE BUBBLY DOWN
GARY'S THROAT.
- BUT--
- JUST DO IT!
SHOW ME HOW STRONG
THOSE LITTLE FINGERTIPS ARE.
[champagne bubbling]
- [burps]
[flies buzzing]
- GARY, WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU DIE?
- THAT DEPENDS ON
YOUR RELIGIOUS BELIEFS,
BUT STRIPPERS PREFER
TO BE SHOVED UNDER A COUCH.
[grunting]
[sighs]
NOW, LET'S GET YOU HOME.
WHEE!
[snores]
- GARY, LOOK OUT!
- UH, WHEE!
- I'M ALL ITCHY, GARY.
- OH, THOSE ARE CALLED CRABS,
KIDDO,
OR AS I LIKE TO CALL THEM,
STRIPPER FLEAS.
- BILLY WATSON,
YOU'RE UNDER ARREST FOR MURDER.
WE FOUND YOUR FINGERPRINTS
ALL OVER THE MURDER WEAPON.
- BILLY, HOW COULD YOU?
- BUT IT WASN'T ME!
TELL THEM, GARY.
- UM, I BLACKED OUT.
SORRY,
I DON'T REMEMBER A THING.
SEE, BILLY,
AND THAT'S THE DANGERS
OF DRINKING ALCOHOL.
KNOWLEDGE IS POWER.
WHEE!